it was one weekend when Herman was
ringing as around saying the BBC are
coming on Friday can we show them a
working prototype and we hadn't built
anything at that point
in fact we just had paper sketches which
had not been really detailed to the
accuracy required to build them and and
the telephone session first he rang
Roger who said don't be daft and then he
rang me saying Roger thinks we can do it
so whatever Roger thinks we can do you
been working for them add hot would you
say or just kind of working for that but
it's sort of mood lighting
who likes yeah big an extra at work I
was on a PhD ranked from the science
Research Council SRO Science Engineering
Research Council it was circ then and
you know that didn't allow me to do paid
work so basically the the deal was I I
designed things gave them the designs
and they gave me more bits to go and
design other things with so it was a
sort of in-kind fuelling of a hobby it
got a bit out of control and the BBC
prototyping week when my part-time
involvement was three days and 2 nights
continuous I think the progression
towards the BBC micro had a number of
steps in it the first one which I had
relatively little to do with was the
development of the Acorn Adam we said
the Adams very nice is going well but we
need to think about its successor that
was acorns position it got the atom in
the market when it heard about the BBC's
interest in developing a series of
programs for which they wanted a
specific machine and for which they'd
been talking to the newberry about their
new brain quite a long time i'd been
involved in sketching out an
architecture that was internally known
as the proton and the thinking there was
we can see the transition is going to be
made from the 8-bit microprocessors in
the atom to 16-bit microprocessor x'
it's a big transition we're not quite
sure the best way to make it we've got a
lot of investment in 8-bit code how can
we exploit that investment whilst
getting into the 16-bit market and so
what we had sketched on the table was it
was effectively a dual processor system
where the main processor was the new
16-bit as yet unspecified but all the
i/o work all the real-time work was done
by the 6502 and in very much the way
we've done it on the atom when we heard
about the BBC's interests and understood
what they were looking for then this
machine was sort of pulled off the
drawing board
and given the cost point they were
aiming at it was clear that what we had
to do was take the second processor off
the standard machine we kept it on as a
potential upgrade which turned out to be
actually very useful but the front end
of the proton is the thing that that
through a little bit of rework became
the BBC micro the BBC had some very
competent people in their research
department thinking about well in
particular of course what they wanted to
use this machine to illustrate on the
programme there's a very important
educational element of learning how to
program these computers first of all
it's fun people enjoy it
so the machine had to do a set of things
that would feature in the programme but
they also were quite particular about
the programming language and BBC basic
emerged as a compromise between you know
Rogers experience of building basics for
earlier icon machines and the BBC's
requirement for a language which was
really rather nicer and cleaner than a
standard basic in terms of hardware the
BBC micro was quite recognizable as the
proton there were some features added
that the BBC wanted that weren't in the
original proton spec so for instance the
teletext mode was not there in the
proton things such as speech generation
as an optional upgrade to your BBC micro
you could plug in
a couple of linear predictive coding
speech chips that would give you a
reasonably faithful reproduction of
Kenneth Kendall I think was was the the
voice that was captured for for that
particular piece of hardware and the BBC
also had some fairly interesting ideas
about peripherals so they came into this
discussion thinking what they wanted was
a zhe running CPM and what we offered
them was a 6502 running a proprietary
operating system but we also offered
them the option of adding the Zed 80 as
a second processor running CPM so we
could kind of deliver on their
requirement at considerable extra cost a
lot of the good features with the BBC
micro were a result of very constructive
dialogue between the BBC and Akon it was
it was a crew it was a creative tension
I mean it wasn't always easy we didn't
like everything they they wanted but
they were they were willing to negotiate
as were we so nobody who went into this
being unreasonable about it they were on
the hardware side for example one of the
things that they were quite firm about
early on was that they didn't want it
the Machine to have a switch mode power
supply switch mode power supplies
operate at radio frequencies they
thought the radio spectrum was their
territory they didn't like equipment
that that created interference in their
spectrum and so the first BBC micros
that we sold had linear power supplies
this turned out to be a very bad idea
because of the physical size constraints
in the case building a linear supply to
fit in the available space was
essentially impossible I mean we had to
Royal transformers and we made them as
efficient as possible but they still
overheated and occasionally caught fire
but it was only after we've been in
production for a few months we went back
to the BBC and said look we really can't
get this supply to work with the
reliability we need let's go and look at
the switch supply and we got a switch
supply that fitted in the same form
factor
I'm by Aztek in Hong Kong a couple of
years ago I went to a retro computer
meeting in the Huddersfield and I when I
went into a room with more BBC micros
than I'd seen in a single room for a
very long time and I'm asking the people
what they need to do to keep the micros
running and basically the answer was you
have to replace the capacities and the
power supply but everything else still
works and the capacitors in these Aztec
switch-mode supplies dried out after 30
years I thought that was a reasonable
reliability record yes the design was
quite aggressive it was based on the
machine I built at home so one of the
key principles was that there was a
single block of memory and the processor
and the display system shared access to
this I'd had this running at home with
the two megahertz memory with one
megahertz with the processor and one for
the display that was a year before now
it was time to double that so the goal
was for megahertz with two megahertz for
a a two megahertz 6502 which of course
is twice the speed of the Apple 2 and 2
megahertz of display which allowed us to
get the 640 pixels across the display
line but that meant for megahertz memory
and that was quite aggressive
indeed we got I think the first ever 16
megabit Hitachi d rams that were single
rails so they only used a 5 volt power
supply instead of having plus minus 5
and plus 12 and and these were the first
ones that are actually fast enough to do
what we wanted if we could do that and
then then it gave us some very nice
performance features we also push the
technology in the BBC micro in using ula
s to integrate systems now that was a
development from the proton design that
came when we looked at the size of the
machine and how much space we had for
chips one of the things that made me
nervous about the BBC micro is that is
that to run this memory at 4 megahertz
we had to multiplex some bits of address
into the row address of the memory some
into the column and the chip we used for
that
the national semiconductor 81 or less 95
okay the numbers engraved in my brain
this was quite a simple chip it was a
multiplexer with a tri-state output and
many other suppliers came along and said
we've got a chip that's an exact
replacement for that why don't you buy
our chip and we put these chips in the
BBC micro and none of them worked and we
never knew why which of course means
that we didn't know why the national
semiconductor one did work right and a
million-and-a-half BBC micros later it
was still working and I still didn't
know why but in volume manufacture
that's the kind of thing you worry about
that the other memorable feature of the
BBC micro is that the poor 6502 s data
bus was seriously overloaded there were
so many peripherals on the machine that
if you worked out how much capacitance
it was driving it was way out of spec
and when we built the first PCB
prototype it didn't work and we
discovered and this is not unusual in
this electronic so if you put your
finger in a certain place on the board
it started working well it's just just
sort of damping oscillations or
something who knows what it's doing
anyway I didn't have enough fingers to
stick one on each of the micros we were
going to build but there is a little
resistor pack across the data bus with 8
resistors pulling the eight data lines
up I think which is the engineer's
finger and again we've no idea why it's
necessary but a million and a half
machines later it was still working so
nobody asked any questions when I
compared the standards to which we
engineer things today the the control we
have over all these aspects then I'm
still astonished that the BBC micro
established this reputation for being
reliable because a lot of it was
fingering the air engineering and
tweaking it till it worked although
perhaps victory over engineering in a
lot of respects possible
oh it was not over engineered if you
took a BBC micro up to about 35 degrees
it would die it was not a good machine
for the Australian desert as we
discovered whereas when we built the
first arm machine where we'd really got
a much better grip on the engineering we
were testing that in the heat chamber
and we could run it so hot that we
actually had to make a little hole to
get the floppy disk outside otherwise it
would melt okay the arms the arm system
in the first Archimedes would run
reliably well above 100 degrees C so the
you know we'd really got the engineering
under control at that point and because
all the components you're using at have
a tolerance okay they all move there
there's that speck moves up and down
depending on which one you pull out of
the bag Wayne so building machines that
work reliably does require that you have
margin and the margins on the Beeb were
very very small and I remember a group
of people meeting in my house in
Cambridge somebody called Roger Wilson
that I got to know a little bit through
the process a group poking around in my
machine and finding a bug in the memory
and that was the first time what you
found a bug in my hardware it was
definitely not the last time